we talked about outlining do you do do
an outline before you write I'd rather
not but usually that's required for the
job like if I'm getting paid for it
they'll they'll want to know right these
days to get hired to write a script you
pretty much have to write the script
like you have to write like a 35 page
outline for a 90 page script you know
turn it in before you can get hired to
write the script so I when I'm writing
for the people I do whatever it takes to
make them comfortable with it which
normally involves an outline me I I just
it's kind of like for me it's not a
musician but I feel like it's like just
jazz you know I feel when it's time for
a change I can feel when you know we
need to know more about a character it's
like it's very my way of working it's
very artificial to say at this point on
page 12 we need to learn that Charlie
has a secret you know what I mean like
because I don't know if that secret is
I'm like do I make it up now or do I
wait until I get to know who charlie is
and you know write that in and like I
feel like the music of it you I just
know on page 12
maybe there's something he's not sharing
with us what and maybe it's this you
know it's just way more organic and I
feel like it flows a lot of times
without lines I'll find when I'm writing
the actual script I won't feel it going
the way that the outline was you know
what I mean so it's either like I do
something false I'm suddenly writing for
me a lot of times especially the rewrite
process for other people's work he's
taking a round peg and putting it into a
square hole it's like here's a movie i
this is an actual true story I had
written a film that was a beach beach
sports kind of romantic comedy that was
set in Thailand the note I got from the
studio was great love it only now it's
in Bulgaria and it's Christmas huh so my
rewrite was too completely and utterly
change the entire you know scenery and
what's happening right round peg square
hole and it's like it's it's like a
Rubik's Cube kind of problem it doesn't
necessarily
- good writing right like when you're
trying to problem-solve instead of
telling the most compelling story that's
that's what I hate about outlining
that's why I don't like being pushed
into a corner by some random decision I
made three months ago when I was just
trying to make people feel comfortable
about what the movie was gonna be does
that make sense
I can ramble about it for the next two
hours because I it's something that I
struggle with a lot when you finish a
script what's your process let's suppose
you've gone through several drafts and
it's for yourself yeah this is not
writing for someone else and you're like
you know what I feel good I've had a
couple people look at it then what's
your process well it's what's cool about
being able to write the movie and then
make it and stuff which is my favorite
of course is that it's never done like
we get a whole new process like once we
get a cast we do I get notes from the
actors I do a read-through with as much
of the cast as I can pull together then
I get notes then we talk about that then
we get on set and well we'll talk about
it then what's great about being in
charge is that I know I'm not
Shakespeare I know that there's always
room for improvement you know and the
key to being a good project manager or a
good director is like being able to
listen to everybody suggestions and then
make a clear distinctive choice and then
stick with that choice you know what I
mean but like I can't tell you how many
times I've been really happy with the
scene and gotten on set and the actor
has said something funnier and I've just
been like well damn it there you go you
get the line that's gonna be in the
trailer and I did not write it I mean I
had Dave Foley in in six month from kids
in the hall and that guy I mean first of
all the only actor to ever come up to me
and ask if he could do a different line
reading like most actors just changed
the line and yeah I I certainly am not
offended by that you know it's like I've
done it myself but he came up to me and
he's like Blaine I have a line
suggestion would you like to hear it
I'm like Dave yes I would and I can go
ahead and tell you that you can probably
say whatever you want and he's hilarious
and he elevated everything
one of his scenes which were pretty
funny to begin with but like that and I
get to take credit for that because I'm
the director I let him say that see
that's that's how smart I am I cast him
and then I let him be him
you